La mentalisation !
Alors je ne suis pas Fabien, ouais, non, je suis Max Bird de la chaîne... Max Bird.
Et je suis là pour une raison particulière, c'est que Fabien et moi, on a commencé la scène ensemble , on s'est lancé sur YouTube tous les deux cette année,
et là on est tous les deux sur le point de franchir le cap des 200 000 abonnés !
Donc voilà, Fabien c'est un peu mon, mon... mon pire ennemi !
Je tenais quand même à le féliciter, voilà, parce que faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an autour du mentalisme...
Il faut savoir qu'il n'y a que 3 bons sujets à faire sur le mentalisme.
5 en étant sympa !
Donc ce n'était pas gagné, quoi, et voilà, grâce à sa sympathie, à sa créativité, le mec il a réussi comme ça à fidéliser...
Enfin "fidéliser"... Le mec est mentaliste , hein!
Il maîtrise l"hypnose, hein donc... Si ça se trouve ces vidéos sont bourrées d'images subliminales qui forcent ton subconscient à s'abonner.
Parce que essayez de vous souvenir du jour où vous vous êtes abonné à Fabien Olicard.
Vous vous souvenez ?
Bah non, vous ne vous souvenez pas!
Mais il a cru que...
Et je vous invite par la même occasion à venir découvrir ce que je fais sur ma chaîne.
Je démolis des idées reçues.
Donc voilà, c'est de la vulgarisation scientifique. C'est clair, c'est instructif, c'est décalé.
Et surtout ça ne parle pas de mentalisme.
En vrai, juste...
Il va passer les 200 000 avant moi,
donc, euh... Si vous pouviez juste venir vous abonner à ma chaîne,
juste, qu'on les passe en même temps, que je ne sois pas ridicule en fait.
Et après si vous voulez vous désabonner... je vous loue! [semblant de pleurer]
Merci !
Cui cui.
Alors Max, on se fait plaisir sur ma chaîne ?
C'est bien, c'est bien, mais par contre tu n'aurais peut être pas dû, du coup, laisser la tienne sans surveillance.
Parce que pendant que tu étais chez moi, je me suis permis d'aller faire un petit tour chez toi.
Et si vous voulez voir ce que j'ai fait sur la chaîne de Max, cliquez, je mets un lien dans la description.
Après j'avoue, je vous recommande d'en profiter pour regarder tout son travail, vraiment, vous allez kiffer.
Bon, et puis comme aujourd'hui apparemment c'est une journée spéciale où Max a piraté ma chaîne, bah il y a eu la vidéo.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17 heures (Mais il s'est trompé il voulait dire 11 heures).
Ciao !
[Musique d'outro]